entre Moscou et qui avait déjà sur la
paille trois mois après sa signature la
Russie se retire on reprise de l'attaque
de drone qui aurait visé sa flotte
située en mer Noire selon Moscou ou les
navires attaqués participaient aux
exportations de céréales
compte tenu de l'acte terroriste réalisé
par le régime de Kiev avec la
participation d'experts britannique la
Russie suspense a participation à la
mise en oeuvre de l'accord sur les
exportations des produits agricoles des
ports Ukrainiens
d'être à l'origine des fuites dont on
fait l'objet les gazeux du gnost cream
suite à des explosions survenues en
septembre dernier les accusations que
Nicki Ève et le ministère de la Défense
britannique qui accuse plutôt Moscou de
vouloir détourner la tension de sa
gestion désastreuse de son invasion en
Ukraine
l'accord s'est réalié conclu en juillet
avait déjà permis l'exportation de plus
de 9 millions de tonnes de céréales en
plus de soulager la crise alimentaire
mondiale provoquée par la guerre
signé pour une durée de 120 jours
l'accord devait prendre fin le 19
novembre mais pouvait être
automatiquement prolongée une
incertitude régnait toutefois puisque
depuis des semaines le président russe
Vladimir Poutine se plaint de ne pouvoir
vendre sa production et ses engrais en
raison des sanctions occidentales l'ONU
pour sa part appelle à la préservation
de cet accord vital pour l'accès à
l'alimentation de millions de personnes
à travers le monde ici Daniel Kadjo
Radio-Canada Montréal